quelques minutes d'attentes avant d'être
testé depuis lundi 21 septembre trappe
accueille un centre de dépistage et de
diagnostic qu'ovide d'ici trois semaines
le laboratoire espère réaliser 500 tests
quotidiens l'espoir qu'on a tous s'est
essayé à la volonté de la rs qui est
vraiment de faciliter l'accès aux
prélèvements dans des délais courts pour
les personnes prioritaires les personnes
prioritaires c'est vraiment celle qui
seraient susceptibles de propager
l'épidémie parce qu elles parce qu'elles
sont positives et parce qu'elles sont en
contact avec des gens cinq opérateurs de
saisie et trois infirmières permettent
un rendu de résultats sous 24 heures
le centre est ouvert six jours sur sept
il est accessible sur prescription
médicale ou pour les personnes
contactées par la rs ou la sécurité
sociale on a détecté hier qui est des
signes de covin mais en fait c'est une
rhinopharyngite comme tous les ans donc
pas précaution comme il est asthmatique
on comprend ça faire le test du copiale
jeudi permanence et mon année est assez
rapidement donc moi ça m'intéresse pour
retourner en cours le plus possible j'ai
des symptômes moi j'ai eu des fièvres
voilà donc du coup j'ai par mesure de
précaution je suis venu faire le test
un deuxième centre est installé à
mantes-la-jolie d'ici quinze jours ce
sont vingt sites qui testeront sur toute
la région francilienne pour la semaine
du 7 au 13 septembre un peu plus de 6%
des personnes testées ont été déclarées
positives
le département est classé en zone active
de circulation du virus